[Music]
better get you sewn up no I'm a virgin
what about the panties panties yes the
panties are you wearing a pen
I wind
[Music]
that's hey guess what I'm feeling a
little cold sore come on maybe we
shouldn't do this for three to six weeks
shut up hello little boy hello
Santa I know that Christmas Eve is in a
couple days and you have to fly around
the whole world and give presents to
everyone and you won't be around anymore
yeah so I thought I'd give you a present
now
what the is it it's a wooden pickle
just beyond this door what is like play
roll like your Xbox instead it's
important that you know you can leave at
any time why what's in there I meant
what I said the helicopters on standby
to take you whenever you want to go you
just open the door so what are you going
she'll okay oh my god
oh my god Michelle should I think you
need to stop okay keep going
well and I made it where's my from you
know I was so nervous she was gonna spot
me
here's the ring son oh let me tell you
something this is some ring look at the
rock on this baby mr. big spender hope
you didn't blow your wad on this son yes
oh just can't resist your intense animal
magnetism
whoops anyway where will it all lead
marriage kids a house in the suburbs
let's just face its fate
no it's not look I've got a headache
and I got the aspirin Oh be gentle just
one good night kiss sweet Becky
come on Howard I was just kidding
oh yeah
what's my name Bobby what's my name
Oh God Cindy who's is it Bobby
whose is it Bobby
[Applause]
[Music]